الجيش الاسرائيلي يستانف عملياته في اكثر
من منطقه في قطاع غزه تحدث عن عوده
المعارك وتحدث عن ان القوات قوات الاحتلال
تعمل على تفكيك قدرات حركه حماس والذراع
العسكري لحركه حماس كتائب القسام ولكن
هناك ربما عدم اتساق يتحدث عن تفكيك وايضا
وزير الدفاع كان تحدث عن انهم قد فككوا
القدرات العسكريه لحركه حماس على الاقل
كتائب القسام في الشمال اليوم هذه المنطقه
جباليا التفاح والدرج تشهد اشتباكات عنيفه
جدا لدرجه ان احد ال او تم رصد رتل توغل
من منطقه غلاف غزه الى داخل المنطقه
الشماليه وممكن المعلومات تتحدث عن ان هذا
الرتل قد يتجه الى المناطق الوسطى
والجنوبيه لاستئناف العمليات العسكريه في
مدينه غزه اليوم كان هناك ايضا قصف عنيف
اسرائيلي و نفذ الجيش الاسرائيلي عمليه
تفجير ضخمه لم يتم تبيان حتى الان ماهيه
هذه العمليه عمليه التفجير ماذا كانت
تستهدف بالتحديد هاجار في مؤتمره الصحفي
تحدث ايضا عن العثور على نفق في منطقه خان
يونس في مكان ما من منطقه خان يونس وقال
ان هناك ايه دلائل تشير الى وجود الرهائن
او المحتجزين الاسرائيليين في مرحله من
المراحل في هذا النفق هذه ليست المره
الاولى في مرات سابقه تحدث الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن رصده انفاق وقيام وحدات
الخاصه بالدخول الى هذه الانفاق وانهم
وجدوا دلائل على الرهائن ولكن حتى الان لم
يجدوا هؤلاء الرهائن هذا ليس الاعلان
الاول من نوعه مدينه خانيونس ما زالت تشهد
قتالا هناك محاولات حثيثه لاقتحام للتوغل
اعمق داخل مدينه خانيونس من اكثر من محور
وهناك اشتباكات اللافت اليوم في خانيونس
انه اذا ما ربطنا الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي وصفت بانها عنيفه على المناطق
المحاذيه للسياج الحدودي التي زن بني
سهيلا وال وخزاعه بشكل خاص تعرضت لعمليات
قصف جوي مركزه والان غاري يتحدث عن وجود
نفق وعن ان القوات المتواجده او القوات
البريه تعاملت مع هذا النفق وفجرت النفق
بعد الانتهاء منه قد يكون هذا يفسر سبب
كثافه الغارات الاسرائيليه ربما لم يتم
التفجير من قبل القوات البريه ربما تم
استهداف هذا المكان ان كان ذلك ربطا سليما
مع ما تحدث به غاري مساله ثانيه تلفت
اليوم ايضا بالعوده الى كلام المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الجراره بلده الجراره اليوم شهدت تفجيرات
متتاليه ومتزامن في بعض المرات ولكن على
اكثر من مرحله خلال هذا اليوم اكثر من
تفجير الشهود الذين افادوا بوقوع هذه
التفجيرات افادوا بانها تفجيرات عنيفه جدا
ولا تستهدف فقط منازل استهدفت اكثر من
موقع داخل بلده الجراره وهي المنطقه
الاولى التي دخلتها قوات الاحتلال عندما
بدات العمليه في جنوب قطاع غزه حسن هذه
ابرز المعلومات وبعض ربطه ببعض ما تحدث به
هاري ولكن حتما المزيد معك
واللواء المزيد من وجهه نظر تحليليه ستكون
مع اللواء فايز الدويري شكرا لك سلام خضر
سيد فايز يعني اكتشاف نفق في خانيونس حتى
ولو لم يكن يعمل يعني قد خرج من الخدمه
كما هو واضح بات يستاهل مؤتمرا صح فيا
ويعتبر كانه انجاز لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما رايك تقدم كبير يعتد به
لانه تم الاحتفال بالعثور على فرده حذاء
السنوار وتم الاحتفال بالعثور على صوره
بطاقه محمد ضيف الان يتحدث عن نفق نعم شيء
يقدم للاعلام لكن توقفت عند
جمله كي يعني يري العالم همجيه حماس كيف
فهؤلاء يعيشوا بدون نور شمس كان المساجين
في الاسرائيلي في السجون الاسرائيليه
يعيشوا في الحدائق العامه يتحدث عن
الاجرام وتناسى ويتحدث عن البعد الانساني
ويتناسى ان جيشه الاسو والاقذار اخلاقيه
في العالم دمر
70% من مباني غزه وقتل ما بين قتيل وجريح
ومفقود تخطى حاجز ال 100000 ويتحدث بان
هؤلاء يعيشوا بدون ضوء نهار وبنقص اكسجين
يا للوقاحه طيب اي سيد فايز ل ننتقل
معك الى الوضع الميداني الى ما اعلنه
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن الاصابات لكن اود ان
اتوقف ولو بعجاله تحدث عن 16 اصابه خلال
ال 24 ساعه لكن اللافت ايضا ان هناك جنيه
اسرائيليا قتل صديقه فور عودته من معارك
غزه الى تل ابيب عن ماذا تدل يا سي كان
هناك احصائيه قبل عده اسابيع ان 7% من
الذين اشتركوا في القتال في داخل غزه
اصيبوا باعراض الامراض النفسيه وقبل ذلك
استيقظ الجندي من النوم وامسك بسلاحه
واطلق النيران على الجدران مما الحق الضرر
بزملائه في نفس المكان وب بالتالي وقفت
محاكمته مراعاه لظروفه النفسيه اذا هذه هي
هم تحدثوا عن رقم
7% انا لم اتحدث عنه انا اخذت المعلومه من
مصادرهم هم وبالتالي نعم هناك معاناه وهذه
المعاناه يعني حتى نكون منصفين ليست فقط
في
اي بالجيش الاحتلال لا في الجيش الامريكي
عندما ذهبوا الى ا افغانستان والعراق كان
هناك اعراض من هذه الامراض وكان هناك
عمليه انتحار الى ما شابه ذلك هذا امر
يحدث في العروب لكن المتباين النسبه نعم
عندما نقول 7% قبل حوالي شهر يعانوا من
امراض نفسيه الان يمكن 20% كما هو رقم
الاصابه بنيران الصديقه طيب بالعوده الان
الى المعارك التي اشرنا الى انها وكانها
مع بدايات هذه الحرب عادت الى المنطقه
الشماليه الى جباليا باي هدف ميداني ب هي
بصوره مصغره يعني لم تعد كما كان ك كما
كانت سابقا لا يعني هي الان تدخلات
متباينه الحجم على سبيل المثال في المنطقه
الشرقيه اول من امس كان التدخل في التفاح
والدرج وكان قوامها كتيبه دروع معززه
بكتيبه مظليين معززه ب سريه مدفعيه ومعزز
بجهد هندسي قتالي هذه في منطقه التفاح
والدرج وتحدثنا عنها في هذا اليوم انتقلت
العمليات الى الجنوب الشرقي من جباليا
وبالتالي
اي لا يوجد معلومات موثقه لم نستطيع
الحصول على معلومات هل هي القوه نفسها
التي دخلت التفاح والدرج وتعثرت طريقها
فحاولت ان تجد مقتربا اخرا تستطيع التحرك
من خلاله في جباليا ام تم الزج بقوات
جديده لانه الفيديو الذي عرض هو عرض داخل
غلاف غزه داخل غلاف غزه وليس داخل مدينه
غزه ولا لم نستطع ان نعرف الجهه او
الفاينال ديستنشن اللي تحرك الى هذا
الكونفو من الاليات المق قاتله ولكن يحتمل
ان تكون قوات جديده هذه هي النقاط الساخنه
اذا ذهبنا للنقاط الاخرى في منطقه الشيخ
رضوان يوجد تواجد محدود جدا مؤطر زمانا
مكانا والاعتماد هناك على ال القناصين اذا
ذهبنا الى الشمال الغربي من الصفطاوي الى
منطقه التوام ابراج الكرامه والمخابرات
يوجد اشتباكات منذ اكثر من فتره كذلك حتى
في منطقه تل الهواء والشيخ عجلين توجد هذه
الاحداث لكن هي ترجمه هي ترجمه لما اشار
له رئيس اركان جيش الاحتلال قبل تقريبا
ثلاثه ايام عندما تحدث صراحه ان حماس بدات
تعيد تنظيم قدرات القتاليه طيب حتى نكون
اكثر وضوحا واكثر دقه الان هذه المناطق
التي تشهد اشتباكات هي
مناطق يعني سبق ان توغل بها جيش الاحتلال
وهو موجود فيها
حاليا يعني ليس في في سياق عمليات التوغل
يا سيدي يعني هذه المناطق در جرى فيها
اشتباك عنيف ولاسابق متواصله ولم تكن
النتائج حاسمه نعم لانه المقاتل بقي وقسم
كبير من السكان لم يغادروا هذه معظ لا
تزال تواجه جيش الاحتلال من حيث عمليه
المنطقه العازله والتهجير يعني الان كنا
نتحدث عن 1.3 مليون متواجدين في القاطع
الشمالي هكذا الاحصائيات بصوره عامه وكانت
بعض التقارير تشير ما بين 700 الى 800000
بقوا في نفس المنطقه وبالتالي الان هذه
المنطقه التي تم الدخول لها لا لا تزال
ماهوله ولا تزء
ببعديها السكان والمقاتل مهه ام كلاهما
موجود لكن عمليا الجيش الاسرائيلي موجود
فيها ولو انه يتلقى هجمات واستهداف من من
المقاومه معارك متحركه نعم هو ليس متثبت
ولم ينشئ ال
ينشئ مناطق انتظار مؤقته كما كنا نشاهد
بصور الاقمار الصناعيه نحن نتحدث الان عن
عن معركه متحركه وليست ثابته قد تتوقف
لدقائق لساعات للاتخاذ وضعيه معينه لكن هي
متحركه لماذا لان المقابل في حاله حركه
الان المقاربه الدفاعيه كما اقراها مختلفه
عن المقاربه الدفاعيه الاولى لماذا لانه
حجم القوه التي باشرت بالاختراق اقل بكثير
وبالتالي يمكن التعامل معها
بمقاربات المقاربه الحاليه هي تعتمد اولا
في بدايات الاشتباك على ما يطلق عليها
الذئاب المنفرده والذئاب المنفرده بالنسبه
للمقاومه هي من واحد الى ثلاث قد يكون شخص
قد يكون اثنين قد يكون ثلاث المهمه الاولى
له الاستطلاع والكشف والابلاغ المهم
الثانيه ان يبقى بحاله حركه وليست ثبات قد
يكون ثبات مؤقت لاصطياد هدف فهو يسمى ذئاب
منفرده متحركه طبيعه اليه القتال هي تفضي
الى الاستدراج الى مناطق تقتيل يكون قد تم
تحضيرها مستقبلا مستقبلا بالحشوات ومن ثم
تاتي مرحله الصد التي تكون هي في
نهايه الدخول دعنا نشاهد اي بعض المشاهد
او الصور لا استهدافات مشاهد لكتائب
القسام يعني ثواني قليله وتكون المشاهد
جاهزه معنا ربما هذا يفسر بالصوره ما
ذكرته استهداف اليات العدو في جباليه
بقذائف
شاهدت هذا الفيديو قبل هذه المره وتحدثت
عنه نشاهد الان مقاتلين عدد اثنين
الان النقطه الفارقه في هذا الفيديو ان
صوره الهدف غير واضحه ظهر عندنا رسم هذا
الرسم يشير انها عربه قتال ليست دبابه
وليست ناقله الجند ولكنها اقرب الى عربه
ال
ال يعني احد العربات القتاليه الهمر او ما
شابه الهمر او ايتان الى غير ذلك يعني
شكلك كانها عربه مدولب ولها تقوس معين
وبالتالي هي في منطقه خارج حدود المناطق
المبنيه هي تقريبا في منطقه زراعيه اذا هي
انا لا ازال اتحدث قبل ق قليل عن الذئاب
المنفرده والبقاء في حاله الحركه فاعتقد
ان الفيديو يعكس ما حد تحدثت عنه شكرا
جزيلا لك بودي ان اسالك العديد من الاسئله
لكن انتهى وقتنا اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي